(clapping)
(background talking)
- [Bonin] Bring it to the beat.
- [Gary] What's up guys?
We're on, hello, hi.
(clapping and cheering)
- Alright, so.
- Alright, alright, everybody,
don't embarrass Gary
because he's wearing
that thing on his head
because of the head lice,
but anyway, don't say anything, okay?
- It's come on strong.
- The bed bugs.
- Head lice this is the new trillion.
- Yeah, oh, jokes.
So, the reason why this was
a very important panel to me
was because I said earlier,
these two people have actually
impacted my life quite a bit
and the one thing I'm
gonna say about Gary,
is that what Gary taught me,
and then I'm gonna, I don't even know
if Gary remembers how we met,
but I'm gonna ask him.
What Gary taught, what I
realized when I watched Gary
was that there's a lot of people that came
from the agency side.
A lot of people that can
come in the room and go,
here's how you should do your Instagram,
and you go, oh my God,
that sounds so smart.
How many followers do you have?
They go oh, I don't have any followers
but this is what I recommend.
You ask Gary, he's like, a million.
Fuck you, now what?
(audience laughing)
Two million, three million, fuck you
now, yeah.
- Do I hear four
million from the audience?
- Not yet, not yet.
(laughing)
- But, and so, what it
took away from me is
if you really wanna understand, you have
to be a true practitioner.
Both of these men are practitioners
and so when I tell people,
text messaging is what
I believe in right now,
I didn't just say that, I wrote a book
and put my phone number on
the cover so I could learn.
Gary told me, look, you're fuckin' around,
you better have video.
So I got a video guy to follow me around
so I could learn what that was like.
You know, and so at the end of the day
I think that that's the one
thing that I've taken away
from Gary, which is if you
really believe that this
is the thing, go practice it
so you can learn that craft,
so you can be the best in telling
other people how to do it.
Gary, how did we meet?
- I think we met at a Pepsi meeting?
- Nope.
- Fuck!
- Uh oh.
(audience laughing)
- Mmm, duh duh duh.
You know where your first
secret wine party was?
- Here.
- My suite, in the Hilton.
- Not true.
- No?
- That was the second.
- Oh, was it the second?
- Yeah.
- Fuck, (laughing) but do you remember?
I, I (laughing).
- Was that the first time we met?
- In the Hilton, you were
walking through the Hilton
and I hunted you down and I was at Pepsi
and I thought to myself I wanna
make Pepsi a digital leader
and Gary's a digital leader.
I said, if I can partner with
Gary, people would believe
that I was a digital leader too.
So I could fake it until we made it
and so, that's how we met.
- I love it.
- I was Gary's first corporate client.
We had 12 people.
- That's exactly right, but no question,
I think Bon and a whole lot
and Pepsi co, they took a shot
at when we were super rag tag.
Other faces and good
friends I see took shots at,
with us early on and those are
the meaningful moments right,
like for all of us, no matter what we do
there's always gonna be a
person that gives you an at bat.
So much of what brings me happiness
is good things have happened
to me which allows me to cont,
I can can give more at bats today than I.
Sometimes I get more at bats
in a month now than I used
to be able to do in a year
and that's just how it works, right?
And I think that especially when you give
without expectation, that's been something
I've been spending a lot
of time with myself on,
trying to figure out
what makes me so happy
and how do I articulate
that as a framework
and I think things that make
me happy is like random music
during a talk.
(audience laughing)
- [Man In audience] Addison!
- Addison in Jersey makes me the happiest,
so you can make that play the whole time.
But I think, I think, no question
the thing that is really.
- He was joking about it.
(laughing)
It was comedy.
- I think giving without
expectation, right?
Super big deal for some we met.
They brought a bunch of
youngsters on his team.
I remember like, remember
like yesterday, and I'm just.
- You didn't even remember
when we met like yesterday.
- Well we met, we're old now.
- We're old, well yeah.
- It's a long time ago.
It was a little more recent.
- Yeah, we're old fucks, okay.
- I think, I think what
really what I think about
and I've already seen
like six or seven faces
and I can remember a lot of those meetings
and I know them, like.
- What, what, yeah.
- When you default into
giving without any thought
of what happens in return,
I'm really fascinated
by the practicality of Karma
and I think that it's one of the hardest
core business principles and so, yeah,
I think that's what you guys
and some of the other
people here did for me
and I try to do for others.
- I had an interesting
experience, by the way,
this conversation for me is
always everybody can talk about
marketing in the industry
and we can talk about that,
but for me it's really like what it takes
to make the person that you
are is more interesting to me
but maybe because I talk about
the industry all the time
but what was interesting is I had
an interesting moment recently in my life
and this was like two weeks
ago, I was in Michaels office
and I said hey look,
I'm doing this for that,
should I ask for this and he said,
you know what, you are more
of a statesman than that dude.
You are more of a statesman,
you don't have to do that
and he kind of laid out to me
and I was and it's the
same thing, which is
and that's always how I live my life
which is karma is much
more important than.
So what would you tell a younger you?
- Oh, what would I tell,
well one start earlier.
You know, believe in
yourself and start earlier
and part of that is,
- Can you grab me a water?
- We are now in an age
of such extraordinary
disruption where, you know,
the iconic players of yesteryear,
I mean one of the things
I think about a little bit is
for about a 50 year period
of time, 1940 to 1990,
not much happened, right?
It was mad man for that entire period.
Okay, we invented a xerox
machine, big fuckin' deal, right?
(audience laughing)
- Dude, you know how many
faces of my butt, I mean copies
of my butt that made?
(laughing)
- It's nasty.
- Anyway, but the, but, and now
big companies, now after 30
years of incredible disruption
big companies have
figured it out, which is
instead of status quo being
the status quo it changes now,
the status quo.
They have in the corporate
suite, come to the believe
that they've got to innovate
and if that wasn't true
than you wouldn't have
had Unilever buying.
- Dollar Shave.
- Dollar shave
for a billion dollars.
You wouldn't have had
- (mumbles).
- Bought Jet being bought
being bought by three by three,
but you know, by Walmart.
So they're convinced now
that stand still and you die.
You got to be like a (mumbles),
you got to move forward
and they know they don't
get it, which is amazing,
which is incredible concession.
- And Michael, to my, to on that point,
I think we're in the middle right now
because I think they think they can
acquire it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is always what a
banker thinks they can do.
The problem is both the
companies you mention,
have absolutely zero shot of
successed readers from today.
They're already finished.
- Yeah.
- If you look at what's happening
with
- I agree.
- if you look at the current state of both
of those companies right this
second, the sole is gone,
the people that drove it are just waiting
for their burnout, and they're gonna leave
and the machine doesn't know
how to take that organ in it.
And so what's gonna be interesting to see
is what happens next.
Are we actually just at
the end of those companies
because distribution in the
middle has been commoditized
which was always their
advantage, the economics,
or will they start understanding
how to create Navy Seals
and Green Berets to go along
with their Army, Navy's
and that's what
I'm watching.
- We talked about them
as pirates, but I think
it's the s.
- Yeah, pirates.
- I think it's the exact,
I think there's two things.
So one is, they're gonna
become distressed assets
potentially which will get
Ball Park guys like you,
which we've talked about
a lot or guys like Amazon.
The second piece is
what they don't realize,
that they're carrying legacy
assets, which is talent.
The sad thing is talent will
be the largest determinate
of success by 2025 than anything else.
Data, energy, it doesn't matter
but if you can't figure out
how to retrain your talent
to be of this generation
you're done and that's what
they haven't been able to do.
That's why they don't succeed.
What are you gonna tell an older you?
What is an older you gonna
think about what you've done
in your life?
- Well what I hope the
84 year old version of me
is saying about me right now?
- First of all it's saying
I don't have a shot in hell
of getting into heaven.
(laughing)
- No shot in hell?
- That's because I think I'm
tryin' to like the same way
block chains doing, what
it's doing to the internet
I think I'm tryin' to do
to heaven with my actions.
Oh listen, I think that.
(laughing)
- Don't even get that joke,
but yeah botching, blotching,
we're good.
- We're getting that later.
(laughing)
- I think that, I think.
- I'll save you
good point too.
- I think a theorem is super interesting.
I don't know Bon, and I
would, I'd like to think that
that version is proud of the
way I'm conducting myself.
I have really big aspirations
to be an all time entrepreneur.
I think that there are a
lot of people who are gonna
make a lot more money and make
far more impactful businesses
than me, but I think I'm up to something
with how many entrepreneurs
I'm impacting along the way.
I know giving up a lot of
economics every year which
for that purpose, and I
think that should play itself
out nicely.
It feels nice to live my
life right now getting
20 to 50 DMS or emails a day
of detailed 15 paragraph
stories of how this one video
or the consistent listening
while they're running
through the podcast, it's
really, it feels nice.
- I got a couple of those
off the back of my book
and yeah, it's, but.
- It's a high that you can't replicate.
- Yeah, you can't replicate it.
- It's funny to me, it's
getting an email like that
or going garage saling and
buying like a Thundercat
for a dollar that I know is $11 on eBay.
It's both those, but I mean
this, this is interesting.
Both those things give me a
bigger high than landing a
$7,000,000 client, they just do.
And I think all of us have those versions.
There's things that excite
you or make you feel good,
that aren't necessarily
tied into the economics
and the business world that you're in
and I think those are things that we have
to pay attention to.
- In 1999, I read Harvard
Business Review for the very first
time.
I read a quite in it and I have
every single printed edition
of the Harvard Business Review since '99.
I read a quote that said,
the mark of a great leader
is where your number two goes to leave.
And so I took that away,
which is always make
the people who work with you or around you
better than you.
And I think, I like to think,
you know the people who've
worked for me that I have
a decent track record
of doing that, but I have a
really important question.
If he buys the Jets,
can we buy the Giants?
- Ooh, rival, yep (mumbles).
(laughing)
- That would be good.
- This is like Jet color almost.
- Yeah, I try to mix
in green at all times.
- Do you like get Mark Gasino dolls?
- I love Mark fuckin' Gasino.
(audience laughing)
- Now we're '99 dude.
- So in kind of that vein,
Michael, so your organization
expanding out, I've watched
this man's organization expand,
it can't just be about you.
So, how do you make sure that
and Katy.
- Have enough kids.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- That's amazing.
- [Lady In audience] I think he did.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How many kids do you have Michael?
- I got six.
- Michaels got six kids.
- And they range from 32 to 20 months, so.
- Actually, before I, before
I actually ask the question
about culture and how you keep the culture
in your organization, I do want to talk.
So, what's the legacy, 'cause
you're very very personal
guy and I know you're, I'm
gonna ask you this too,
but what's the legacy
you wanna leave your kids
or the message you (mumbles).
- Right, well I
so when I'm asked that question.
- Well not even legacy
like assets, but like.
Sorry, you got it.
(audience laughing)
- You'll tell me if you're
unsatisfied with the answer.
But, it's what I wanna do is
I wanna prove Keet's wrong.
So Keet said, "Our names
are writ on water."
Alright, so like this, it's gone.
I wanna build in a legacy I wanna have,
it's gonna be enduring.
I want somebody like you want, right?
To, somebody to point to me
and said I learned something
from that guy or he built something right,
or he changed something,
he made things better
and I want that to be remembered,
not just not Michael memorial
service but for a decade
or a century after that, so that's.
- Awesome.
- What I wanna do.
- Gary, I know you're very personable,
I will not ask about family,
but I just wanna know
as a father, like what do you want them
to take away from your life?
- You know, I hope that
they say, you know dad felt
so much guilt that Grandma
and Grandpa put him
in such a good position to
succeed, that he did the same
for us out of a payback for them.
My entire, you know.
- And they let you love
comfortably for the rest
of your years (mumbles)?
- Yeah look, I, to me I
am perfectly parented.
I really believe that.
- Okay.
- Which is a very, I mean it.
Which is a very, I'm driven
by gratitude and guilt.
I'm very aware of that, that
what they did was so all time,
that I feel a sense of
giving back so much so,
that it's not just to
my children, I'm tryin'
to use modern technology and communication
to give back as a whole.
I was really put on by
really special parents
and put me in a real position to succeed
at the face of what was
politically correct at the time.
I'm an immigrant, who in the
80's and 90's every Russian
kid that came over during
that time with my parents,
education was the way out, right?
We were all poor, we all lived
in studios, education was
the way out and my mom
created air cover for me
to be an entrepreneur
when the word didn't exist
and I'm unbelievably grateful for that
and so I just want my kids
to feel like I put them
in a position to succeed.
I don't want them to be
entrepreneurs, I don't want them
to be anything other than
whatever makes them feel
the way I feel about my game.
I wanna support that and I
think the greatest mistake
in our society right
now is that parents feel
that children are a product
or an indicator of who they are,
which allows them to
manifest their insecurities
on their children.
I wanna do the reverse of that
and I wanna put them in
a position to succeed.
- Damn good, you're like a father dude.
(clapping)
I've known this man for a long time
and that's some grown up shit man, wow.
(audience laughing)
That was, okay.
So, to that, and then I
started asking Michael
but we're gonna come back on this.
Gary you had, I've met
you, you had 12 people.
How many you have now?
- 850.
- 850, how many offices?
- Four.
- Four offices.
So, it can't just be about
Gary, although your name's
on the door.
How do you make sure.
- Doesn't really fit
on the door.
- Yeah, well both of your
names are on the door,
by the way, but he's got his
nice signature.
- That's why I chop
the Chuck part out.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that's right.
What, how do you ensure that
the people who come into that
organization new, understand
what you were tryin' to build
or are building?
- I think.
- And is it hard?
- Everything, anything great is hard.
I think, I think there's two
things that I think they pop,
they pull from opposite directions.
When you asked that question,
the first thing that runs through my mind
is moldable dictatorship, right?
There's just four or five things
that I believe in tremendously.
- So you definitely are Russian.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
You know, you know,
I think it's super important
to know what your three
or four religions are, right?
Empathy, you know, it
really matters to me.
Attention really matters to me.
The current state of
culture really matters
and we have to create that
way, we have to strategize that
way but if you bring up my
15 or 20 direct reports,
a lot of 'em will talk.
If Ryan Harwood, I
bought PureWow last year,
if he came up here, he's like
I didn't even talk to
Gary the first six months.
I tend to be
- Lucky him.
- very hands off other than if people are,
to me the key things are,
are you trying to succeed by
tearing everybody else down
versus just building the biggest building?
That to me is like,
something I really spend
a lot of time on.
Look, managers by nature,
don't have the luxury
that the person that has
the name on the door has.
Which is, I'm to logo.
I've no vested interest if my CFO is right
or the entry level accountant is right.
My vested interest is
that the logo is right.
So I'm able to be agnostic.
For a manager, there's a lot
of people that live their lives
that when they hit $315,000 a
year, that's a real mitzvah,
like they made it, like
that's what they want
and what happens is they
switch into defense.
They were on offense their
whole life until they got
to the point where the work life balance
and the money and what other
variables in their lives,
it's set and then they go on defense.
And what they're doing is
they're suppressing anybody
who wants to encroach on their territory
which naturally are the
people that work for them.
And I spend an ungodly amount
of time paying attention
to that dynamic.
Everything else I feel
comfortable with at this point
in my life.
I now feel confident in
my intuitive understanding
of human behavior and how
it impacts communication
and products, so I'm gonna
continue to bet on that skill
and that will lead us
in the right direction.
Voice, AR, ML, whatever it may be.
- Text.
- You know, of course.
(audience laughing)
- I told him about text.
He was like nah, it's not that big.
Now he's like, text me!
(laughing)
- Please.
Good thing I record everything, we'll see.
- Alright, let's go back.
Clear the videotape.
(laughing)
- I think, I think that
that's what I spend
a lot of time thinking about.
Empowering them to no end
while making them accountable
for two to four things, that really matter
at the end of the day.
- I spent a lot of time thinking
about being inside a large
organizations and the problem
is they're pyramids by nature
are built to create that situation.
And when I always used
to tell my team is that,
so even when I almost poached
to go work someplace else
from Andalese.
I could have said give me the
person when they asked what
do I want to stay, I could have
said give me somebody else's
role, but instead, I said
let's increase the pyramid.
Give me E-commerce and then
we have a hundred new people
underneath the E-commerce job.
Well that's very hard because
everybody thinks getting
to the top means you have
to step on the person above.
- That's right.
- And so, culture, how do you maintain?
- Well I, I, as Gary was talking
a kind of an expression that
I had or philosophy that I had
and I didn't invent it but
I think it's very true,
which (mumbles) exactly
what you're saying,
A people hire A people and
B people hire C people.
And A people hire A people
because A people says,
Oh my God, if I hire somebody
better that they're just gonna
create opportunities for me,
I am totally secure in my skill,
I can quit my job and
get rehired any time.
Well they feel fine about that.
It only, they know that
only makes them better.
B people it's all about
preservation, the preservation that
you talked about and they have to hire C's
because they got to be smarter
and better than the C's
because that's how they
assure their own preservation
in the pyramid that you're talking about.
I think that the new workplace
and the workplace that you
have, the workplace that I have
are kind of different
people work in teams.
It sounds like you're the type of manager
that I also try to be
which is just walk around.
You talk to anybody in your organization.
You put up their feet, your
feet on their desk and you say
what's goin' on?
Tell me what's goin' on.
What are the three things
goin' bump in the night
and it's,
if you have a traditional organization
that just drives them nuts.
It, what are you, you're
talkin' to one of my peop,
why're you do.
You can talk to me about that
and it's like yeah, I can,
but I wanna get their point of view.
So that has followed me around.
The A's and A's and B's and
C's and always try to hire A's.
The tragedy is at different
times, and this was your point,
and A becomes a B and
that becomes very hard
because when they reach that,
whatever that number is,
and all of a sudden they become,
it moves from advancement
and expansion and
generosity to preservation.
And when it does that, then
it's really problematic
and it just happens
and it's sometimes kind
of with tragic results like
I'm building a business,
all of a sudden it becomes really big,
I'd love to push that person
up but all of a sudden that
A became a B.
- You know what's
interesting about that is
we've been spending a lot of time on
and I did this kind of anecdotal.
It's fun to have some of
the faces in this room.
I always thought if
somebody wasn't gonna be
in my organization anymore,
I appreciated them being
in the organization so
much that I wanna do
anything I could to help
them in next chapter.
We're taking it so extreme,
that we're creating an internal job board
because right now where
I'm sitting in the world,
so many people are asking me
for help for their hiring,
and I.
When you were talking I
said yeah, one of the.
I'm sorry I'm about to
go around a little bit
it's how my brain works.
The reason I was starting
to tell you this is
when he was talking,
the thing that happens
is unless you're able to grow
the business at a rapid pace.
- Yeah, the A's.
- You can, you have moments where you
can't feed all the A's and so
like sometimes they tap out,
but sometimes the company taps out
and it can't feed everybody
and that also creates a
scenario.
One of the things that's
happening for me is
because we've been marketing
slightly different than a lot
of people and that is now
becoming a little bit more
of the accepted practice,
we have a lot of talent.
And a lot of C's are starting
to think and are B's.
A lot of B's are starting to
think and are becoming A's
and I can't feed all of them
at the speed at which they're
growing in comparison to how
the overall company's growing.
So that everybody wins,
I'm spending a lot of time
thinking about what would it
mean if I take real talent
and how do you get people comfortable
to raise their hand and
say, yeah, I do wanna be
the CMO of that startup or
I do wanna go client side
and work at Mondelez.
It's scary right, because
if they don't get the job
then they think they put themselves
in a vulnerable position.
I think the thing I spend a lot of time on
is how do I eliminate cynicism
within the organization
and that's very very difficult.
I mean people, when they leave Vayner,
I try to meet with them
and I just had somebody
who left after four years,
just got to that place
and she said literally
the entire 15 minutes,
she's like, I don't understand
why I didn't come to you
when you've done everything
to create a scenario where
you want me to come to
you but my coworkers
came to you like, I am
not that kind of person.
So, and I'm empathetic to that.
I don't like to go to people either.
So, it's just a constant battle.
You're always battling it scale
and that's what it's about.
- But we're lucky that we
have expansive organizations,
right, you went from 12 to 280.
- Yep, were.
- 850.
- I'm sorry, 850.
I'm at 280.
850, and I
guess I revert, so anyway.
But, whatever it is it's.
- The same shit.
- Very very very rapid
expansion, so you can take your.
- You can feed.
- And if you can't feed it's problematic.
I wanna come back to.
- And don't let me
forget this.
- Yep.
- Finish that but I wanna
say one thing about raising
capital versus making
money around feeding,
but go ahead I don't wanna
forget this way you'll
remind me.
- Yeah,
there's so many interesting
topics we can talk about
including the whole
venture thing which is,
(mic vibrating)
yeah, right, exactly, you see that?
(audience laughing)
- Well.
- I thought it was Michael
Jordan next to me for a second.
- I actually think you guys
have not spent enough time
talkin' about models that
he has
- We just haven't
spent enough time and.
- and that you have
and how those, because I think he's got
an interesting model.
- Right.
- Go ahead, what are you
gonna say because (mumbles).
- Well, okay.
So what I was, because you
talked about big company
and some buying, right, buying in.
Then once they bought, that
transplanted tissue, right,
gets rejected by the body and that,
we have seen that sad story.
- Over and over.
- Over and over and over again
and it's almost that the flip of that,
that it actually works and
it's integrated as a rarity
but there is a reason a long
time reason why big companies
don't experiment and
try to buy the winners
and it's because the drum beat
of earnings releases every
three months if you're a public company.
You cannot afford draining
blood out of the system
to make an investment in something new,
particularly when it
has a high failure rate.
Venture will tell you,
Venture guys will tell you
two in 10 are about the odds.
The shareholders would go nuts.
They would say what,
give me 80% failure rate?
Why are you doing that?
Right, and you can't just take a bunch
of money out of earnings
and put it into something.
And then, we get to the problem of
you don't have anybody
in your organization
because it's been a pyramid for so long
that really can take a risk, an event
because there are more B's than A's
and there're really into
preservation as opposed
to inventions, so they
wouldn't take that risk
to begin with.
But the other bias of that
is when you buy a company,
when you buy a company, it is not,
it is not in a pyramid to your profits,
it goes on your balance sheet as an asset.
So there is a technical
bias to buy not built.
And so that is one of the
reasons I think on a DNA level,
institutional level, why
big companies cannot invent,
and it's more than they
just don't have the talent,
it's the structure.
- What Wall Street has created,
a scenario where these are
no longer companies, they're
financial arbitrage machines.
- Yep.
- That's what they are.
- And then they have
jockeys that ride the horses
as long as they can and
then usually get thrown off.
- And make decisions
- Well because.
- on their self interest on the way out.
- Because, you know, they
used to call Time Inc.
if, it used to be
called, it was Time Life,
the time of your life building
and that is because you
just work there long enough,
you retire between 55 and 60,
you're a millionaire.
Guaranteed millionaire,
comfortable retirement,
that's all that you had to do.
So the name of the game
was don't screw up.
- Right.
- You would say that don't fuck up.
Anyway, don't screw up, just don't, don't.
You know, I didn't listen,
I got fired but anyway,
just don't get fired.
- It worked out.
- It worked out okay, but anyhow.
- Yeah, no, I
but the other thing that's
bad about it is that
the scale of those
organizations can actually
change that dynamic from two and 10
to potentially six and ten
but yet, there's not room for that
because the leadership has
never seen what the failures
of those small businesses are,
to understand how large scale
organizations can fix those.
And one of it is just
distribution and access.
So like if we had, I tried to buy
the first receipt scanning platform
and I said to the organization,
it was a distressed asset,
it was 12 million dollars.
I said look, we're gonna
make this a defacto standard.
We're gonna put on every
single one of our packaging
and they said yeah, but
none of our competitors
are gonna use that.
I said, I don't care
about our competitors.
There's 1200 categories
in a grocery store,
we represent 10 of them and those 10,
all the rest of the categories there
but we're the only people who
get it to scale fast enough,
but they couldn't see their way out of
there.
- Yeah.
- Now imagine if we had owned
Check Out, this was before
Check Out 51, before all those.
Imagine if we had owned that
or I tried to sell him Animal Crackers.
We had a $250,000,000 movie deal.
Animal Crackers is a $20,000,000 business.
$20,000,000 business we didn't
care if it fell off the truck
but yet we could double it,
triple it and then we had a
movie deal and they were like,
we don't see the economics.
I was like oh my God, you're killing me.
What do I have to do.
Sorry, go ahead.
- Right, right.
Well no, but this man is incredibly rare
because he was a rebel inside
of a very giant business
and he actually succeeded.
- Some days.
- I'm not talkin' about
the (mumbles) ever,
just so you know.
- Well, but I mean, well
but it was an incredible,
I mean you spent, I mean
imagine all the energy
that you spent instead of
fighting your own organization
to like inventing, right?
It was probably three
quarters or maybe 90%
fighting your own organization.
Your leal departments
saying, I can't do this.
It's like what, it's a word,
what do you mean, I mean
what are you talkin' about.
Anyway, but it's.
- I mean, that's where you
guys crossed paths right?
You guys have similarities in that.
- Yeah, that's true.
We started with big companies
and tried to reinvent them.
There is a book before
I lose this thought,
called Creative Destruction
by a guy named Richard Foster,
a Mckinsey guy.
It is supposed to be a manual,
right, for big companies
of how to reinvent, but when you read it
it becomes very clear
that they're screwed.
Forget it, it can't happen.
It is example after example
of how they are so lame
when it comes to invention
and he gives many many
great illustrations of that
but you have to ask yourself the question,
why, when all of a sudden
we went from oil lamps,
used to be whale oil, right?
That's what lit every
city and all of a sudden
became oil oil but all
the actors that were
in whale oil, none of
them went into oil oil.
The wagons that won the West,
the Conestoga wagons, right?
Why didn't that become Fisher
Body and General Motors,
they just didn't and why, right,
why now that it does take a musk, right,
to bring the brand new automobile
when these big manufacturers
are not leading,
they're following.
And it has to do to the
fact that it becomes,
if you remember Shawshank
Redemption, that talks about
being institutionalized,
they all become institutionalized.
Front to back all the organization,
every piece of capital and
infrastructure and skill base
is built for this machine
and nobody elevates it
to 35,000 feet to ask what
business that we're in.
So why.
- They're no longer,
they're no longer incentivized
- Right.
- to do.
- But why did Amazon invent Amazon, right?
You would think, right, why
didn't Kroger invent Amazon,
right?
Why did
- Or Barnes and Nobles?
- Why didn't.
- They're like.
Oh shoot, how'd that happen?
- So right, Barnes and Noble.
(audience laughing)
Damn!
Well, you know what?
Actually the first steps is denial,
nobody's gonna buy a book that way,
- I was told.
They gotta look at
it first.
- When I took
E-com they said, are
anybody ever gonna really
buy an Oreo online?
I was like oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah, so.
- Meanwhile, we take it 65 to 265.
- So, literally five
years before Google, okay,
Time Inc. invented the first Google
and it was called Pathfinder, right,
except the mistake was that the
only fact you could find out
was contained in Time Inc. titles.
And the thinking was well shit
if it's not in the Time Inc.
title, it's not, who'd
wanna do anything outside?
So it's like .
- It's stage news.
- So it failed miserably,
right, but the idea is that
the people in this room are the
people who are gonna realize
the future.
If you look at this
country and we're all here
because we love this country,
you look at this country
and you look at some of the
great, great, great companies,
the Facebook's, the Amazons,
they're from here, right,
and it's because we are very adaptable
and we are all capable
of this reinvention,
creative thinking and
I guess I'll end one.
- No, no, no, we're not ending.
- Well my view's just by saying
that being an entrepreneur
is the hardest, bravest
thing that anybody can do
and you've got to be .
You can't do it well unless
you are all in, all in.
- Or.
- Or you're all out.
- No, I mean, or you're capable of dealing
with other people's opinions.
The reason people struggle is
because when you're an
entrepreneur it's really fun
to work somewhere, right?
When you work somewhere,
when something goes wrong,
including if you get
fired, you blame your boss.
My boss fucked me, right?
Like entrepreneurship
difficult because there's
no wiggle room out, you fucked up.
- That hashtag goes for (mumbles).
- Like everything that's
wrong in my company is 100%
my fault, like every, and there's hundreds
of issues right now.
I hired the head of that department,
I created that process, like
everything runs through me.
And I think people struggle
with entrepreneurship more
because they're worried about the judgment
an you've got to be able
to be numb to that feedback
and that is not most peoples make up.
- Yeah, no, I agree with that.
I'm learning that to be honest with you.
- And Bon, I think the
thing that's happening,
one thing that everybody
here has to understand
is like look, we've lived
through eight or nine years now
of economic prosperity.
There's a fuck load of
people running around this
town right now that think they're special,
they've never made money any month
they've run their company.
They've lost money every month.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Like people cheer raising capital.
You gave up a piece of your business.
- So Gary, I'm gonna ask you a question.
- Sure.
- So there was something like
160 plus or minus unicorns
minted last year, alright,
well hold it.
- Okay.
- How many of those, right, how many
of those will be around
three years, five years
and how many of those founders, right,
one billion dollars is the
valuation of this company.
How many of those founders,
right, are gonna walk away with
a meaningful amount of money?
- Probably 10 to 20 % will
be around and do their thing
and 80 to 90% of the founders will leave
with meaningful money.
- With meaningful?
- What of those
- Well yeah.
- 10 or 20?
- Yeah, because once they get.
- Yeah, but of those 10 or 20.
But here's the import,
but here's my point every.
- One more time, I wanna make sure we're
agreeing because
- Good.
- I think 90% of the 160
right now are gonna leave
with meaningful money.
- Really, I don't think so.
- Yeah.
Well, first of all, it might
just be we have a different
definition of meaningful money.
(laughing)
No, it might, it might, it might.
No really, we might, I mean that meaning,
I think somebody who runs a company
and is extremely good at raising
capital for a company that
eventually goes belly
up but she or he is able
in series C and D to take
home 10 to 30 million dollars
and take it home is meaningful money
for something that ended
up being a house of cards.
- Okay, my definition
and yours are different.
(laughing)
But what I, but the reason
why I anchor that as 10 to 30
is one to three percent of the
whole shooting match, right?
I mean these are companies
worth a billion plus
but we do agree on this,
which is most of them
will just go puff, right.
So think about that.
They've been exalted by the press, right.
160 unicorns, right, unicorns
and they're gonna billion
dollar plus and the bulk of them
are house of cards, the bulk
of them have never made money,
the bulk of them are really a product
of financial engineering
and good salesmanship
and by the way, a financial
community that adds
more money than it has,
either brains or deal flow
and there's a certain urgency.
- There's too much money in the system.
Guys the biggest.
- How do you feel about
venture Gary?
First of all, can I just
tell you me and Gary,
this is, this'll be the fifth
year that we've done this.
Everybody who I put
between us gets chewed up.
- Oh my God.
- And this is the most
docile I've ever, I'm like,
oh my God it's working.
So I've brought the big gun,
I was like ah, put Michael
right in front.
(laughing)
- I'm holdin' my own!
- I think.
- How do you feel
about ventures?
- Look, the biggest
financial loss in my career
personally was 15 months ago or so
when I decided to not close
out the find that I was raising
and give back everybody's capital,
yet, I was carrying the talent
and anticipating the 2%
management fee on a $150,000,000
fund and took a complete blood bath.
And I do think $10,000,000
is meaningful money,
and so like I'm not
in the business
- I'm cool with so (mumbles).
(laughing)
- I'm not in a pla, I came from zero,
so when you come from
zero losing seven figures,
out of being noble feels really fucked up.
And so, it's the most proud
I've ever been in my life
and it happened because as
I was raising this fund.
- Yep.
- I just woke up one
morning and said holy shit,
I don't believe in this game right now,
and so what am I going to do, lose?
Because I, it's funny, losing
that money was really smart
because I know myself which is,
if I ran that fund and that money got lost
and it would of because
if you don't believe
in something completely,
you're now guessing.
The reason I've been
good, I don't predict,
like people, he predicted shit.
I don't predict anything,
I fuckin' execute early
and then I communicate about it.
And so I don't guess and so like for me,
when I don't guess I'm investing
in Facebook and Twitter
and Tumbler, like I did early on
and when I'm, guessing I
looked more like the investor
I was on the back half
and I just knew that shit
is fucked up.
I'm very down on it right now, I have not
invested meaningfully now for two years,
I'm really struggling with it.
I will get back in the game
because I genuinely believe
in Voice and I will absolutely
bet on apps built on top
of Google Home and Ama, and Alexa.
So I'm excited.
- Yeah.
- It's the first time I'm kind
of feeling like I'll get back
in the game because I've seen
this rodeo before, right,
because these are apps on top
of a device that will matter.
Spotify and Waze and Instagram,
these are apps on the iPhone.
And so, I'm excited about that
but how do I feel?
I feel very negative about it.
I think there's a bunch of B
and C and D and E and F players
who think they're entrepreneurs
and old time entrepreneurs
because it's cool, we put on a pedestal.
I think people raising a bunch
of capital and burning cash
have no idea what the fuck they're doing,
aren't building actual
businesses, are building on top
platforms that have all the
leverage, they have none.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And I'm just not into it
and I can't wait for shit to hit the fan
and carnage and blood
because, and I mean it
and I mean it, here's why.
Because in the game of
business merit should prevail,
like you shouldn't win if you suck.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- So.
- And so everybody who's rolling
around with keep.
- I'm screwed.
- And so everybody who's
rolling around with a tee shirt
of their start up and
think they're special
and are really pumped about
like, I raise, like guys,
listen to the conversations.
- Yeah, I know.
- Every conversations I raised.
- [Man In Audience] Yeah.
- I raised this , I raised that.
- I raise children.
- You know what I mean?
(laughing)
- You know?
- But it's
interesting because, so Jet,
so Michael to came from zero.
Got fired had the paycheck in his pocket
and built this business brick by brick
but what were the things
that kept you up in the night
when trying to build a
real business versus,
so the biggest thing that
you hear in the venture
conversations is the most amount of time
and you talk about this too
that a founder will spend
his raising money versus
building a business.
- Correct.
- You say that
to me all the time.
- Yep.
- And the reason why he built
the incubator he has today
is because he doesn't want
the founder to spend time
raising money.
He doesn't think
that that's
- Yep.
- important, money is easy.
Businesses are what's hard,
and so just talk about,
I feel like that (mumbles)
- So.
- is built.
- First of all, one
thing, I think one earmark
of an entrepreneur is
the fact that, no, no,
that you grew up really
hungry and I think of
all three of us.
- Oh, a 100%.
- All three of us did that.
- I grew up real fuckin'
hungry, I'm not gonna lie.
Go ahead.
- I know. (laughing)
- Still starving, let's
get this goin'. (laughing)
- Your makin' up for it. (laughing)
- So the.
- You got time Bonin. (laughing)
- But a.
- You just said we were old earlier.
- You know the fact that I'm
(mumbles) is.
- 'Cause you got a lot of.
- Fuckin' time.
- The fact that I'm, but
there's so many things
we can talk about but, I think one
of the more important things
about being an entrepreneur
is having a North star
because if you are in the weeds, right.
- You know, Rich said that
to me the other day too.
Rich Dennis, Sundial.
- Oh he did?
- Yeah, it was interesting
to hear (mumbles).
- Oh, okay, so.
- If you don't know your finish line.
- That's right.
- You have no idea how to
- fuckin' navigate.
- Because in the day to day, right,
in the battlefield day to day
all sorts of ugly things happen
and if you don't have a 35,000 feet view
your compass will, you'll just be a loss
because if you soak up
every day you're gonna
have some victories and oh my God,
you're gonna have three
defeats in a row and if.
- Do you love micro defeats?
- Do I love micro defeats?
You know what I love?
I love being what Edison
said, right, you remember it?
No, you don't, okay.
Edison, said.
- You're only old enough
to remember Edison,
we're not.
- Me too.
We're pals by the way, we hung out,
New Jersey was good.
(laughing)
- So, but what he said was I never failed,
I learned 10,000 how
not to make a light bulb
and that's what I think
exactly what you're getting at,
micro defeats.
Yes, you've got to, they're not defeats,
they're learning opportunities
and we talk all the time
about quality at bats.
Right, you can strike out but
what I demand is a quality
at bat, right.
- I think Michael, I
think the problem there
is too many people in this
room and in this game are
looking for the short
term economics, right.
Like I mean, back to you have time,
I think the reason people
struggle with micro defeat
is because they're
looking to do it so fast.
The amount of 20 year
olds who think by 30.
- Oh yeah.
- They have to have their
multi million dollar thing.
You just see it in people's
behaviors, you take short cuts
and then when you're taking short cuts,
you make fatal flaws not short term flaws.
- And that is, by the
way, one of the things,
we have an internship program
and everybody there wants to
be an entrepreneur and we kind
of say okay, let's level set.
Number one, this is not college, right.
When you're in college, you're a customer.
You're not a customer, okay.
Everybody here has their hair on fire
and the answer to whatever they want.
If they say get me
coffee, the answers yes.
Don't say wait a minute, I
spend $70,000 a year to go
to Yale, right.
To get somebody else.
I mean, fuck you, right.
I mean, we need coffee right now.
Why?
- You shouldn't have
fuckin' paid Yale
- Because we're gonna be,
we're gonna be workin'
- dick.
- for the next 23 hours straight.
(laughing)
So number one, you're not
a customer anymore, right?
And number two, they do
have this visual that
they come up with an idea on Monday,
on Tuesday they raise capital,
on Wednesday they've got the MVP,
one Thursday somebody buys
it for a biz, for a billion
and on Friday they're in Saint-Tropez.
(laughing)
And, you just gotta just
disabuse them of that
and because that's just not how it works.
It's a lot of hard work,
it's front to back, eight.
- It takes time.
- Yeah, it takes time.
- Well you get, we can't
go to Saint-Tropez?
- We have a Saint-Tropez.
- So wait, it's interesting
because Rich Dennis who Sundial,
I was his chief growth officer for a year,
they just sold to Unilever
a little under a billion.
Everybody's like oh my God Rich,
oh it's amazing, I can't believe what
you've done
- Yeah.
- And when you talk, it was 26 years.
The man started selling soap
on the corn, first of all,
he escaped two Revolutions.
They had to get his
family out as refugees.
He learned how to make soap
- African (mumbles), right.
- For Arica, in Africa.
Not Revolutions here.
(laughing)
- Yep.
- Learned how to make soap
- What's next?
- from this, yeah.
They lived 12 people in a
three bedroom apartment.
Learned how to make soap
from his Grandmother,
used to sell it in a village
and started selling bars
of soap on the corner
in Harlan dude.
Like, and then to cut
to have a $300,000,000,
largest natural beauty business
and then to sell it, I mean,
you're just like that see.
But Gary, I've watched you,
I've watched you for two years
but I watched you do,
and that's what people
don't understand, Gary came to me.
12 people, 30, 60, and he was like okay,
what do big agencies look like?
And we had a heart to heart
and I was like here's what I know
and what's interesting to watch,
every single move that Gary,
wins, losses, rearchitecting,
shifting, and Gary still gets,
I put the beauty business in his business
and when I saw some of the
things I didn't like about it,
he still gets an earful from
me on like, this isn't right.
And Marcus gets an earful
from me all day long
because I know I can get him on the phone.
So but yeah,
I think that people underestimate
how long it takes
- Look, but.
- We're gonna take two
questions so people get ready,
and then we're
gonna share them.
- Yeah, let me
just say this, I think
advice is interesting.
I think it always matters more
when the person that's giving
it to you actually lived it.
The thing that I get razzed for
the most on the
- I agree with that.
- Internet, happens to be the thing
I'm single most proud of, which is
I entered my family business, right?
And so like a lot of people
when I put out contact will say,
well why do you listen to him,
like his family put him on.
I went into my family business.
which is a three
- Yeah, but it wasn't.
Yeah.
- But it's
even better and I've never.
Do you know I'm not even
sure if you know this,
I've only started talking about
it for the last six months
and you've been too
busy for me, so let me.
Let me say this, it's easy for
me to give advice for people
to be patient because
my true life story was
at 22 years old I went
into my family business.
I took my family business
from a three to a $60,000,000 business.
I owned zero percent of that business.
I never got paid over $100,000
because it was a family
immigrant old school business
and when I left at 34
and started Vayner Media,
the reason we were so humble
and started in Buddy Media's
fucking conference room, you
would think somebody who built
a $60,000,000 business, I left
that business at 34 years old
had no money and no equity to my name
because the business was
completely owned by my dad
because I'm part of an
immigrant family business
and you go in and you
build it for your family
and a lot of them end up, the
dad leaves and you take it.
I had a different path.
So here I am at 34 for
all you 20 year olds,
zero to my name, right.
Never got paid a 100,000 a year
and had the chip on my shoulder that
I actually built something
from three to 60.
Me, I built it and left with nothing.
That's, so I started.
- So you did say you loved
your parents though right?
- I love 'em, like I.
- He was so clear
on that one.
- But it's still,
Michael it's important.
That's the best thing I
ever did, I paid them back
for all the amazing things they did.
I, that feels real whole for me
but people are just so impatient.
I only started it then
and I had a grind then
and I had a scratch then
and so and I've done a
whole lot in eight years
because I learned a lot in
those years that I was running.
You could do a lot, listen,
a lot more of your stuff,
stuff happens later in people.
When did you start really getting like.
- Late 30's man, yeah.
- It's not tomorrow and it's a late 30's
on the experience of 20 years
or 15, 18 years of good execution, right?
And then you can start
saying obnoxious shit like
$10,000,000 isn't meaningful money.
(laughing and clapping)
- Alright we have two questions
and I'm getting a shout down.
Carlos go ahead.
- [Carlos] Gary, speak about
the value of mentorship.
- You know, look, you
mean from the perspective
of being a mentor or having one?
- Having one.
- [Carlos] You talked
about A, B and C players.
What's it gonna take for
someone to go from being D, C
up to A?
- Look, I think everybody
does it different right.
Like I will tell you flat
out, I've never had a mentor.
Not even my dad, right.
Like I'm an inside guy, I'm in my own shed
but I don't think that's cool.
I don't think inside
you, I think it's a flaw
if you want to be frank.
Every time I've been open to hear shit,
I'm like oh that helped
me, and like it's just
not my natural being.
I think the value of mentorship actually
has much more, Carlos, to do
with the individual, right.
Like I've watched you
from afar for a while,
you pick up things from other
people and you've got like,
everybody's different.
I think the key is self awareness.
The key here is self awareness.
Who the fuck are you and how do you learn?
I knew how I wanted to
buy the New York Jets.
It was by buying nostalgic
brands and flipping them.
I knew that I had to eat
shit for 10 to 20 years
of running an agency
to learn all this shit.
Now I know what to do but 10
years ago my thesis was right,
I could have gotten the capital,
I could have done it, but I didn't know.
I needed, the way I learn is by bleeding.
- We talked about that.
- Right?
- Tryin' to get you to buy Mug Root beer.
- That's how, that's right.
That's how I learn, I need to taste.
So I don't need a mentor
because if somebody telling me something
is why I got D's and F's.
I need to just go and taste.
Other people really get
value out of mentors.
I watch people, I give
'em one piece of advice
and I'm like, how the fuck did they run
with that shit and do all
the you know, you know?
(audience laughing)
So I think self aware, if I
could give everybody here,
besides health, it's self awareness.
'Cause once you have that unlocked
and you stop bullshitting
yourself of what you want
to be versus who you actually
are, shit starts changing.
- [Carlos] Wow.
- Yeah, okay, another, go ahead.
Just shout it out.
- [Woman In Audience] I
think, what's the worst advice
you've given?
- Michael.
(audience laughing)
Quit, that was the
worst advice!
- Fine, quit your job.
(laughing)
- It's a good question.
- Oh, yeah.
- I can answer it while
you're thinkin' about it.
I think the worst advice
- I'm just slower in the
snaps (mumbles).
- I give is when
I make it through the eyes and
ears and filter of who I am
as a person, I think way
too many people give advice
predicated on themselves.
A lot of the things I look for are themes
and, but I spend a lot more time looking
at the collective than myself,
because there's a lot of nuances about me
that doesn't map for other people,
so I think way too many
people' advice is to singular
and they don't have empathy
to understand the subtleties
of everybody else around them.
- I think it's interesting
Gary said that he's in himself.
I ran into Gary in Turks and
Caicos in a random situation,
random situation and Gary
had just stacks of books.
He was like phone is off, it's me, family
and like this introspective
moment to read.
You were reading Steve Jobs,
- Yep.
- at that time, it was really,
really interesting insight
though.
Very personable person, but
I don't think people know
because he's so outward.
Worst advice you ever gave?
- I answer that?
So, I'm gonna restate the
question a little bit.
When do I give the worst advice,
and when I give the worst advice
is when I'm tryin' to be nice, right.
When I'm tryin' to be polite.
- Which comes super not natural to you.
- It's true.
(laughing)
It's true, but basically the worst advice
is when you read the
person on the other side
and you tell 'em what they want to hear,
- Yeah, that's so right.
- as opposed to the truth.
- Absolutely right.
- The truth is tough
and sometimes you just
- I struggle with that.
feel like you gotta do that
but yes, it's
- That's a really good point.
- When you tell them
what they want to hear
and not what is real.
- I'm being told to stop
but I'm gonna get that.
I'm gonna take two more questions
'cause this feels to me like
one of the most truthful panels
that you're gonna see
in South by Southwest
and I'm very excited about it personally,
so two more questions.
- [Camera Man] Gary, time is it.
- I know brother.
(laughing)
- Two more, two more.
- Shut your fuckin'
mouth T-Rock.
- Two more.
(laughing)
- T-Rock.
Two more questions or that's
it, we're gonna shut it down
if not, alright.
- [Man in audience]
You're two of the best.
- Thank you brother, thank you.
- In the back, just yell.
- [Man In Audience 2]
How do you guys reconcile
a little work life balance?
I mean honestly being
extremely busy but you,
still going on with family and
that sort of thing (mumbles)?
- From my standpoint, I think it's insane
to pander to the current
state of political correctness
around parenting because it
evolves every 10 to 15 years
based on our overreaction
one way or the other.
I think we beat ourselves up too much.
I handle it super well,
I know what my intent is.
I fuckin' love my children
but I can't love anybody
if I don't love my life and
so I'm willing to be selfish
to be selfless, I'm also the byproduct.
It's very individual, I'm not
gonna, I could never think
to give somebody advice
on raising their kids
or running their family.
None of us know what's going on
in somebody else's fuckin' home.
You don't know how well
it's working for me.
You don't know how my wife
and I were brought up,
why that works for us
because we're used to it
and it's our conditioning.
You don't know that.
So cool, you wanna tell me like
'cause you feel good about
yourself coming home at 5
but meanwhile you're on
your phone the whole time.
Like the judgment of other
people's parenting is asinine.
I handle it super fuckin' easy.
(laughing)
- Michael.
- Alright, I'm, I'm.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe we should ask Katie.
- Work life balance.
I think number one, you gotta
love what you do, right.
So if you love what you do, if
that's, if you love what you
do it all kind of blends together.
For one thing you're
comfortable within yourself,
you're a satisfied person.
That's by the way what
makes you a great parent,
is not coming home and
being a son of a bitch
'cause you're pissed off at
what you did for the last
12 hours.
So I think that if you
love what you do then
you're kind of a satisfied
content person then it just.
- Works itself out.
- It works itself out.
- Go, just real quick.
- [Man In Audience 3] What do you want
to put on your tombstone?
- He gave more than he took.
- Oh my God.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Actually it's so
interesting you said that.
You're just an interesting guy man,
we should hang out more often.
But you can't speak first because, anyway.
But.
- It's my default.
- But, one time I felt
that in one of our exits
somebody benefited more
than I thought they deserved
and my partner brought me back and said,
you know what, if your tombstone reads
here lies Michael Loeb, he
gave too many people too much,
what about that?
- You've won.
- And I said, you know
what, I can live with that.
That totally works.
- Alright, block or not?
- Blotching, extremely bullish.
I think that it's unobvious
technology but I think there's
a bunch of fuckin' losers in it right now
and it's early as shit.
- Yeah.
- So it reminds me very early internet.
There's a bunch of club
promoters and hucksters
and real estate agents and
social media experts and.
(audience clapping)
But, that's exactly what
happens when new shit happens.
- When I was in there, yesterday I was in,
I was like this is exactly
like the early internet.
Wait a second, I've seen this.
- And that's what fucks with smart people,
they see the people associated with them
and they're not smart, they
think that is what represents
it and that's why they
underestimate it but the technology
is black and white.
It is a meaningful technology.
- Is it luck or go ahead, you wanna?
- So basically you're blotching,
you're talking about the offensive
line for the Jets, right?
Much I know.
No, it's gonna be very
- I gotta go.
- very important.
- Luck, is it about luck or not?
- Oh, part of it is for sure
but they say that, what's the expression,
that not that you make
your own luck but that.
- Preparation that whole thing.
- Yeah, yeah, that's right, what is it?
Your younger than me.
- Yeah.
- [Man In Audience] She meets opportunity.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Yep.
- Is luck and. - Peter Guber
said to me miracles happen
to everybody, you just need
to be prepared to accept 'em.
- Yeah, I think luck is
an interesting one for me.
I have a little bit of a different take.
I'm curious in the
context that it comes out
of somebodies mouth.
So I believe in chance
and all these many things
and luck would have you but I think that
most of the time when
somebody spits that word,
it's because they're not in
the happy place with themselves
and are tryin' to justify why
somebody else got something.
- Ah, okay.
- We very much struggle
with responsibility
and taking on responsibility
and we like to pass it on to somebody else
and we're trying to justify
why we're not winning
and we like to throw that,
that words being thrown around
by a bunch of fuckin' losers
to try to make themselves feel better.
- Right.
When, I misunderstood
you in the beginning,
when I think you and I would
both describe ourselves
as lucky.
- Sure.
- Right, and but
when you assign that to somebody
else like he was successful
because he got lucky,
that is what losers do
so, right, the wrath.
- Judgements a real mistake.
It's a real mistake and
we're all doing it at scale
right now and it's really a mistake.
You're just, you're deploying it like,
I think it's back to that mentor question.
I really am tryin' to figure
out how to allow people
to start really thinking
just as much as possible
inside their own frame
because envy and judgment,
it just brings,
like putting any energy like
I only want all of you to win.
There's so much abundance
- But he wants a couple
of points (mumbles).
- to victory.
- No, I want zero.
(audience laughing)
What I actually want is to
figure out if I'm better than you
on merit.
Like I want all of you
to win, I wanna win more
than all of you.
I genuinely think I
will. (audience laughing)
I mean it, I mean it, but if.
- I'll give you
10 to 30 million.
- But if I don't, but
if I don't, I'm pumped.
- Alright,
- I'm like you fuckin' earned it, you won.
- Alright, last words?
- Last words, oh my God, that
sounds so. (audience laughing)
- Last piece of advice.
- Last piece of advice,
last piece of advice
is that I've never seen a
period of such wrenching change.
Me and Edison used to talk
about this by the way.
Anyway, but such wrenching change
and you guys, everybody in this room,
you're gonna herald that change.
It requires a great deal
of conviction and courage.
You've got to again have
a North star to guide you.
In other words, the speed
bumps of everyday can
be a little deflating
but you can't let that
damage your spirit.
Surround yourself with great people.
We talked a little bit about advice.
The interesting thing
about advice, don't listen
to any one voice, gather a lot
and then kind of tease out for that
the really interesting opinions and
but do, it does take a village.
Be generous, pay it forward all the time
and create that community and
the only one way to do that.
Look if you're an
asshole, you're not gonna
be able to do that.
Everybody's gonna figure that out.
You've got to be a good
and generous person then
create that network that
is gonna be supportive
of you good times and bad.
Your turn.
(clapping)
- I think the biggest
thing I would leave with is
something I've been
spending a lot of time on,
is just stop judging yourself.
Everybody else is doing
it for you already.
- [Man in Audience] That's so true.
- I mean it, like you need
to get past that part.
If you're not in that right
place, you got no fuckin' shot.
You can listen to advice all fuckin' day,
you've got to stop judging yourself.
Everybody else sucks at shit too.
(laughing)
- And not to intenerate this
but I'll share one other thing
and it has a lot to do
of what your saying,
but I'll say it better.
Anyway, but.
- Much more long winded.
(laughing)
- Alright Mr. 10 billion,
but anyway the. (laughing)
But, what detachments an important word
and there's a thinking in poker that
if it's your life savings in the middle
of the table you're done, right.
You're just done.
It's got to be bits of plastic, right,
and if you don't have that detachment then
you're just junk, you're just done.
- It's a really interesting
point, like it's
funny to me.
- Thank you for that.
- No it is, it is a super.
I will say this, it's a
super interesting point.
It's unbelievable how
unemotional I am about business.
For all my energy and
everything that you think about,
like it's, I'm completely numb to it all.
Like if somebody screws
me or this and that
or I lose, like it just
I think the detachment
is such a variable into
why it works for me.
It's just, I don't feel it that way.
I think it's the cost of entry
to play this game
and that's why I think there's
so many fake entrepreneurs
right now and why I'm nervous.
An entrepreneur likes
getting punched in the mouth
and that's a very different mindset.
- Yeah, and just because I've
got to get the last word, but.
(audience laughing)
- Well, technically I'm
going to get the last word.
- But you're right, a lot
of people revenge right?
Lose the revenge thing
people are gonna screw you
and you just got to move on
and you just because it just
the wasted emotion and energy.
It's gonna happen, right?
Guys are just gonna fuck you.
They just will, so go ahead.
- Well look, so we have
bread bought in the back,
which is Automated
Autonomous Bread Bakery.
Let's give them a huge round of clapping.
(audience clapping)
I don't get a bye?
- [Gary] Love ya.
- [Bon] Thank you, alright sir, be safe.
Everyone thank you but
definitely go see our (mumbles).
- [Man in blue] I shared that I had,
we have a mutual friend.
- [Bon] I have a (mumbles) that I brought,
right by here for a (mumbles).
- [Man In Blue] We have a mutual friend,
Casey Adams (mumbles).
- You're the best, good dude.
See you guys, take care (mumbles).
See you Carlos.